this week conflict zone is in Brussels
to speak to heal the kharkova the
European Union's counterterrorism
coordinator in the latest spate of
terrorist violence 12 people were killed
in Barcelona in mid-august with
thousands of jihadists living on
European soil posing an imminent threat
is Europe doing enough
[Music]
mr. de coca welcome to conflict zone you
member states reported in 2016 that 142
I repeat 142 victims died in terrorist
attacks and 379 people were injured 2017
is not over yet but the numbers will be
higher this is dramatic this is huge I
do agree and and very sad does it mean
that we failed
I wouldn't reach it that confusion oh I
142 people and their families would say
rightly so no it's rightly so and and
and and but we prevented other plots for
plots and arrest people who were
planning more but not enough because
regardless whatever you prevented it
never before in the last years we had so
many people who died because of
terrorist attacks but it is true so I
have to accept the harsh criticism that
we should have avoid that so we need to
fix it and even improve further the
position you are holding the you counter
terror attack or de Nader was created as
the result of the Madrid terror attack
in 2004 here we are in 2017 after
another big attack in Spain 13 years
later
Europe's continues to live in fear even
more than ever before it's true in a way
because the the threat of terrorism has
not reduced we've seen increase the rise
of an organization beside al-qaeda -
with franchises an affiliated group in
several part of the world there are many
more people attracted by these are the
ideology and so it is a concern indeed
and it just reinforced the point that
the trade is first serious but much more
complex than it was before because we
have at the same time loan actors which
are not necessary linked to - with Syria
and Iraq operating by themselves and
using pretty banal weapon like a car or
a knife not a banal weapon this happened
in Israel and other countries years ago
when Europe didn't understand what
happened there yeah and no nothing you
tend to look at this because of of what
did happen Europe started to look at
this on the time when it happens here
indeed on cars on the use of cars
example is not something very new no but
but you will never prevent someone
leaving his apartment taking a car a
knife in the kitchen and keep someone in
the street I'm sorry you have to detect
the person much earlier and and that's
the work which has been undertaken for
years on training better community
police officers using more and more no
sophisticated software to spot weak
signals so when is it that someone gets
radicalized and in reach the tipping
point where it will use violence but it
looks like that the terrorists are
quicker and more effective in the last
year's in Europe then the security
institutions are to prevent it and these
are facts look Europe is under attack
and the EU does not have a good answer
or a better answer to this threat I
acknowledge that we need to improve but
I wouldn't draw the conclusions that
Europe hasn't done anything as I said
before very sadly many attacks have been
prevented many plots have been fall but
but of course some have succeeded there
is very sadly enough nothing likes and
the % security but we have improved a
lot with all due respect this sentence
we don't have
100% security is the sentence I'm
listening
every time when a terror attack happen
nobody is asking 100% but it doesn't
look that the situation of the European
police institutions and intelligence is
helping that the attacks are going back
less successful I think we have to first
see that - is not winning the the
long-term goal they have so far the
physical caliphate is collapsing so the
anti-isil coalition managed no to
destroy the physical caliphate for
example the attackers in barcelona they
follow a trend very well known also by
your work they were organized by radical
Imam of North African origins this time
in Morocco who has who was known and
that's the important point who was known
by the police and this is a repeating
pattern I don't have all the details and
the vestigation will tell us more well
all of what what went wrong
but that is precisely the current
challenge is to to be to be better at
spotting weak signals because all the
expert has shown that now the most
radical people are using what I call
takea dissimulation so as to to to to
operate below the radar so this is now
the big challenge for the security
services in the police is to be better
at a analyzing it's not just a question
of exchange of data because in many
instances as you suggest the data was
available but it's more to make the
right assessment of the tipping point
when the person would use violence and
this is this remains and we can
summarize this was a failure but there
is another thing which is very
interesting with the terrorist act just
now instance
Spain was informed about a possible
terrorist act also in Barcelona also in
the place where it happened this attack
could have been prevented
if the Spanish security forces wouldn't
have decide you know what this
information is not something we have to
react on so what is the reason to inform
each other when at the end of the day we
have a terrorist act with a lot of
people who died we will learn from the
Spaniards who are currently they said
that it's true they were informed we
have to talk about this concrete thing
because the public is owned by the CIA
that's what you mean
no I don't know from whom but that it
happened that the Spanish security
forces got this information in May this
is now effect like you I've read that in
the newspapers that the CIA might have
warned it was informed but but as I
understand because I don't have all the
detail the initial plan was not to
target people in the street with a car
but more to have explosives to blow up
the city
so what Barcelona and the place was
known they didn't take it as seriously
as you have to because perhaps the trust
with all these organizations also your
organization is that the cooperation and
the trust in the information is not high
enough I wouldn't say the trust is not
there that all services are not
effective I won't agree with this as I
said I have not enough detail on what
went wrong to draw like you such bluntly
the conclusion that he was at
information that he was informed this is
a that's what that's it that's what you
say and maybe they they took some
measures that I'm not aware of it's not
my role to assess exactly or - this is
not your role you are the coordinator
you are the man for you I'll tell you
I'll tell you my roles not a role is to
learn from not only successes but
mistakes and recommend policy
yes you're learning and things like that
are still happening will most likely
happen again I'm afraid there's been a
lot of hope last year that the launch of
the ECT C will change things I reported
in January 2016 that the launch was
organized with 39 staff members and five
national experts 16 less than 50 people
processing intelligence to secure 500
million Europeans 50 people yeah that's
it
let let me explain the EU is not the
prime minister for Internet Security
member says are the prime responsible
the treaty have been drafted accordingly
and member states are the solely
responsible for intelligence so that's
the decision of the Member State I have
to operate in the legal context the
treaties and and and and that's the role
of the European Union is to support the
Member States by providing data starting
with 50 for the European Union for these
states more than 25 it's at all it's not
50 you have a thousand people at the
European counterterrorism center
how many are you in India it's it's when
Europe all cross data on crime and data
on terrorism you have to look at the
people working on the analysis of the
data the collection the treatment of
data in a different Department it's a
single agency with a single management
in integrated policy that you need more
Human Resources Europe all ask for more
indeed and I'm in favor of adding
resource yes how many two hundred
percent five hundred percent more I hate
first the need expressed by the people
in charge Europe all has a director if
I'm not mislead you have an get from the
Commission additions if my additional
resource and and I'm confident that they
would receive this additional resource
but it's not moving from 50 or 60 to 500
it's not the point me that this is one
of the most important
questions in Europe a special sir way
from April 16 showed majority of
Europeans feel like a quote that EU
action is largely insufficient
sufficient and they would like to have
the EU to intervene more so what's
stopping Brussels from doing that
Brussels is very forthcoming I'm sorry
because precisely the starting point in
the treaties that we were and we are in
support of the Member States because of
what you just suggested that 82% of the
citizens would like to see more Europe
in the field of security we are
investing a lot the president of the
Commission's launched the idea of a
security Union if you think of the
monetary union is full of a very
ambitious project he appointed a
full-time commissioner Julian king who
is monitoring implementation of the
security union and we have developed a
lot of new policies adopted a lot on
legislation supported a lot of effort in
the Member States to collect the
passenger name record information about
the example the passenger name record
that you advocate for the proposal was
considered initially in 2011 six years
ago and we are now hoping it we are
hoping it will be implemented by May 18
seven years later seven years and we are
speaking about security we are speaking
about terrorism we are speaking about a
threat and the fear of millions of
Europeans I fully share your concern is
the consequence of difficult negotiation
with the European Parliament where many
members elected members of parliament
were worried by the the impact on
privacy and insisted on adding a lot of
safeguards in terms of data protection
and eventually we managed to reach the
consensus there is an in the court of
justice in recent sometimes worrying
decision have squashed some of our
measures because they believe that it
was breaching privacy and so Europe is
too slow or will never be a fish
and enough to excite again this is what
we are saying terror the institution are
keen to strike the balance right between
privacy and security and we don't want
to rush to become a big brother Society
and therefore that takes time this sort
of discussion takes time we are partly a
Big Brother society a lot of information
in different countries are saved in a
different way take Germany with very
high level and other countries who don't
have this level know the European
Parliament in the Council adopted
recently to legislation on data
protection I must say the level of
protection in Europe is probably the
highest in the world and member states
companies private companies and law
enforcement agency will have to abide by
these rules so it is untrue to say that
they are discrepancy no the relationship
of others who are even less taking
important about civil and other rights
the attention that Europe is the best
but it's not because it is the best and
the highest level of protection of civil
rights but let's talk now about the
defeat of Isis
it seems you just mentioned it it is a
good news that in Iraq and Syria there
are a lot of defeats of Isis but the bad
news for Europe is less war more
terrorism in Europe would you agree
first we have to finish the war if you
call it like this and and dismantle
completely the Caliphate and neutralized
all the members of - but not just -
would be a mistake to overlook al-qaeda
or Taha IATA here al sham extra button
was ready franchises of al-qaeda but we
have to win the peace and that's another
challenge we have to ensure that the
sunnis we're supporting - in a way do
feel well both in Iraq and in Syria and
that's part of the challenge that's not
the only places were jihad
this or other terrorists growing how
many returning jihadist we have now 17
2017 in Europe I don't have an exact
figures per day issue we at some stage
where for you to see to see a massive
return and it's not what is happening
for some reason first because it's no
longer possible to cross the border with
Turkey as easily as it was before the
organization is killing the defectors
and you said yourself it's a war an ugly
war and many of the fighters are killed
so for the time many came back how many
do you think in Europe let's say a third
I think of the 5,000 when they have
probably already 50 I enough to destroy
the security of a country like France or
Germany so how do you monitor these
5,000 people who are a danger for our
security first you need to spot them
when they they try to come back so at
the external border and that's why we
have improved significantly the check at
the external border by imposing a
systematic check on usage know that they
are clever enough some of them but but
if we were not doing it you would
criticize it so we took some quite tough
decision it was not an easy decision to
impose on EU citizens to be controlled
when they cross the external border we
did we changed the Iranian code we have
no improved a lot the way we performed
the security check at the Excel border
especially with the migration flow so
come back to you should we allow even
these jihadis to come back into the
European Union in principle yes because
German citizens has the right to come
back but it's up to the German authority
to to stop them and and start
prosecuting that provides him and from
the right exactly
ban the entry of some and even revoke
their citizenship when possible do you
support the idea it has been discussed
in several member states but it seems
that according to international law you
cannot strip someone from in citizenship
here if he has only one citizenship we
know now that even if and when Isis is
defeated its ideology the sentiment it's
provoked they keep on living online you
refer to it as quote the rise of the
virtual Caliphate what are you doing to
fight in order to this we've been very
active the Commission set up a
public-private partnership with the big
Internet companies at the request of the
member states to explore how to improve
the removal of a lawful content quickly
and as much as possible and we have they
achieved quite significant result we
have set up at Europol an internet
referral unit which so far has flagged
more than 30,000 unlawful content 90%
more of the line live you can control
the digital sphere wait let me finish
we've removed 90% of what has been
flagged to the companies and we put a
lot of pressure on them so that they
developed algo hidden to detect in an
automated way in lawful content 70% of
what Twitter is removing is no done on
the terrorists are not only working on
Twitter they are working in the digital
world with elements we even don't know
one very concrete question Germany just
now for example announced it wants to
extend border controls beyond November
something the Commission is not
supporting is Germany right to close the
borders where China in Germany Germany
borders but the member states have the
right to establish on a temporary basis
internal Bolger hole but it should not
be the rule in forever
absolutely let's talk about another
threat the Balkans how concerned are you
about what is happening there in terms
of radicalization and support for terror
we are engaged with the Western Balkan
states
I was recently very concerned they
themselves are concern are you concerned
and very concerned not very concerned
but we have to work together because day
two
1,000 of the citizens mainly coming from
Bosnia so Covina from massive former
Republic of Macedonia and and Kosovo
have been joining what are you doing to
improve the situation with the Balkans
so they are engaged in an accession
process so we help them to implement the
EU a key in terms of border management
we help we train them we provide them
with equipment we've helped them to
draft the necessary legislation have we
have we have I understand that we have
but time is running out and a report
from Europe poll last year only last
year talked about I quote a radical
Islamist ideology promoted by radical
preachers or leaders of some Salafist
groups in some parts of the Western
Balkan region this is in your own
backyard this is Europe and we have what
did you what did you do but I said we
they know all of them have no
legislation making it a crime to go to
Syria and Iraq which they had not before
so you have to go through Parliament
these are democracy we are training the
police and we are setting up mechanisms
so that they exchange among themselves
and with your poll most of them except I
think one have an operational agreement
with Europe all I'm sorry but that means
something that means they share the data
with Europe all that we get the data as
well we are helping them on the prevent
side preventing of categorization
addressing the issue of the ideology
trying to stop radical Imam propagating
the ideology so all these are concrete
steps not just dogs it we are working
together but we know for example that a
munitions and weapons from the Balkans
were used are used for example in
Charlie Hebdo in Paris but a claw
attacks what can we do more to combat
this illegal weapons entering - very
good point
the remains of of the Vatican were
millions of arms
still available and I do agree it's a
concern that's why we've improved again
on legislation we have adopted a new
legislation on the trafficking in arms
Europe all has concrete operations in
the Western Balkans with the Western
Balkan states but may I raise one aspect
when say the positive aspect but why is
it that in Barcelona they use knives and
they didn't succeed in in weaponize the
TATP explosives and why did the house
blow up you may ask yourself is it a
consequence of the measures that we have
taken that is not that easily
Araya t it may be you may say it could
be a consequence of the measures of
whether they could we make it more
difficult for people to get access to
weapons so we have to look at all sides
but still at the Balkans you have so
many weapons that you can destroy a
terrorist act a lot of societies - we
are working with each and every members
of the Western Balkan states to find
ways to dry up the market the eagle
market of firearms let's talk about
brexit this is coming at a very
sensitive and crucial times in terms of
security is it it is and it's a bit
early to discuss the the way we will
work with our British friends after
breaks it because we don't we want first
to make progress in the divorce like it
will be a very hard divorce we know best
friends hopefully I'm not in charge of
that but but it's clear that on both
sides there is a wish to keep a very
close relationship same as being a
member if you are in the club there is
another relationship then what wins for
security reasons in Europe maybe the
blinkin consideration that the Britons
are very important in intelligence and
they are excellent it's one of the
Member States we supported me the most
over the years but we will develop with
the Brits what we are developing with
them
against every intimate a very same you
are in the family they won't sit at the
management board of year ago probably no
but at the same time nothing prevent
will it be worse from your experience
and point of I don't believe so
and first let me tell you that as
intelligence falls outside you
competence nothing changed in the remit
of of integers exchange mr. de kerkhof
thank you very much for coming to
conflicts in a reservation
[Music]
you